quando sulle mie cuffie sasha non sei a
un dottore anche ciao a tutti benvenuti
questo nuovissimo video se volete una
pallina di gelato sono qui avere 50 più
bei ragazzi siamo come siamo su questo
gioco che bisogna scendere dopo giorno
ma può un gioco è una cosa è un gioco
bisogna scegliere se fare una cosa o una
all altra cosa in questo caso c'è tipo
salta l'estate saltiamo l'inverno chi è
che salterebbe restare davvero nella
vita
e vero stiamo l'inverno l'altro abbiamo
messo in italiano ma sarà una traduzione
fatta simile a quella rebellin salve
sarà even milione essere d'accordo
500mila e disaccordi e d'accordo
che schifo ma non è che ho fatto
qualcosa va bene di disney dieci volte
ti tolgo la parolaccia di prima per i
friendly averlo nei disney disney per i
resti essere conosciuto e riconosciuto
come razzismo ma poi di nazista peppa
pig peppa pig per parlare essere
conosciuto come mascolini sale anche i
maschi l'isna salve in inglese lario che
le quote il becco giocare line
linebacker becker e credo sia angeli
alla bella bega e che erano né
pasticceri l'inglese sincero quello che
prende più soldi va bene nel mondo
invaso dagli zombie o vive nel mondo di
malaga by little pony bellissimo dove
sono 53 pensavo molto bene
nel carnet preferiresti avere la
sensazione di essere preso a calci negli
stimoli per 12 ore al giorno quelli che
fanno bene la traduzione non pensavo
fosse per essere non essere in grado di
produrre vampirizza io preferisco fare
bambini sarà anche attivati ma incinta
ciao e me diciamo messico tanto messo
allenato plateau o promo fate una doccia
fredda ogni giorno aree batteva rendere
so la doccia calda solo una volta ogni
due settimane
la doccia della parola che ricordo che
fa il fisico perché tonifica la doccia
fredda quindi quindi quella casa di due
settimane magari di state va bene anche
il vialetto governo con la figlia
preferirsi vincere un oscar a vincere il
premio nobel nel premio nobile noi non
siamo noi non siamo andati a trovarlo
turni poi l'oscar la vince chiunque si
manco è tutta gente che dice io voglio
sempre intelligente ma non ti caga di
meno tua madre proveresti indossare
sempre il cappello a cilindro o
indossare sempre una collana gigantesco
orologio
ok io no io lo pago affido
ecco come direttore allo stesso tempo
combattere 10 tori uno alla volta di una
volta e tipo di una scalata al milione
di gerry scotti arrivava al toro la 2
milioni non è un altro più grosso 3
arriva da punture tory ma cosa perché
così dico che non vogliamo subito a
volte se ne sconfiggi uno dei
sconfiggere anche le cose belle per
essere vicino sorda sentirete due minuti
più tardi e bastardi kg cos'è tipo lag
82 minuti più tardi essere vicino a
sordi maestro sordi grandissimo sordi
essere un senatore stati uniti essere o
diventare il presidente del senato e
presidente chiari guerra a tutti il
rispetto per la poca cosa sta roba
infatti come fate a comprato anche i
voti sul suo esatto è si è più bello di
persona più bello in foto di persona a
persona di persone classi personale se
sei bella sei [ __ ] sul sito ma dal duo
fai schifo
rep meglio fare schifo sul sito 4 per
cento per il vostro stomaco tirato fuori
dalla tua bocca avere il tuo cervello
tirato fuori dalla vostra cavità oculare
a non ho chul han di telefono lo stomaco
ciao a tutti ragazzi in questo nuovo che
si tira poi lo stomaco vince dai non
essere in grado di indossare abiti tutti
nudi non è stringher di parlare di
minuti a cesare florio è bello essere
noi come 45 nel segno di parlare come
mamma ci sa fare meglio e ferirsi sapere
che esattamente quello che è successo ad
area 51 accettare un milioni di
accettare salari ogni limite sardo vilk
accertare dollari milioni di milioni mi
fai accettato mia devo andare in giro a
quattro zampe per tutto il tempo solo
fare i rumori degli animali come fa papa
che li parla come gli uomini
[Musica]
[Applauso]
beh abbiamo già deciso dopo questa mia
specifica avere treni polso e un capex e
potrai cappelli a forma di vino e caffè
a raga raga
mare o montagna direi che ultimamente la
montagna anche la mala ascolta ma la
[ __ ] dell'aperto si vede nulla va in
spiaggia spiaggia
lasciamo perdere ma se suolo te stesso e
non essere in grado di pulire da soli o
cambiare i vestiti per una settimana
indossare lo stesso vestito per un anno
io a suolo tester è di non vessare lo
stesso vestito per un anno la aeree
andare sul titanic ed essere
sopravvissuto conosci nelle torri
gemelle quindi rimorchi a testa a stare
nelle tre gemelle venire quando è venuta
colpita italiano poi da 130 volte ti
cani sotto la cosa mi il gusto di a jack
porca [ __ ] sia sulla cazzo di potere
passa per altre sei persone e la cosa
mai avrà il teatro dei pugni a quelli
che stavano di avere rubato i salvagenti
anche a gente che va a donne e bambini
lancia un gelato in da jean loup avrei
gusti lanciare mangiare solo kfc per un
mese o sott'acqua belli e stato bello di
chicago bella piazza ci ho mai mangiato
più belle file bull rizzati pulito e ben
collegata o problematica partecipo e
capace abolisse hfc
quindi divertito la casa mentre noi a
puntare i piedi di ii vc poterlo
ricostruire ma che cazzo ti piaccio di
carrozzelle e dai e noi puntiamo in
piedi
ci manca solo che amputi miei piedi e la
ferragni può accompagnare vede come lei
va bene la colla gli occhi chiusi con la
colla super spill con la caldo sopra il
vostro giro nuda
aprite qualsiasi un esploratore andare
della giungla amazzonica o nel
sottomarino verona ragazzi della casa
propria ma se non voglio aprire a
ragionare giochi la mazzoni che non ha
però mai puoi scappare sotta così ti
acchiappa nulla ma non può vivere con
hitler tre anni vivere con saddam per
sei mesi a tre anni di hitler che sei
cuse meglio nota come saddam hussein
meglio un giorno da iter che cento da
drogati e severo ci fanno gli articoli
contro che siamo nati stime più di pai
parla tutte il suono surround con il
caso il basso ciao proprio tema di
ingresso quando si chiama tipo che ogni
volta niente una stanza di parte a
colonna sonora i genitori proprio anche
parlare in surround e di essere
allergico ai bambini e le persone
bambini e bambine rispetto i bambini a
volte mi stanno davvero sui quali bump
ai vecchi bestemmioni bambini era un po
sulle scatole neanche bestemmie dai
ragazzi questa è la chiave per ragazzi
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio sasha ringrazio salvo per le
perle di saggezza di questo vi ricordate
meglio essere allergici e allergiche
lo shop online i ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto ringrazio sasha ringrazio
salvo guardalinee gli stanno dicendo
però state registrando
quindi ragazzi se avete vissuto una
situazione momento e mi piace anche vari
social comunista descrizione lascio
anche i cali di salvo e di sasha nella
descrizione noi ci diventa come un mouse
emilio mouse
stefan da ragazzi
[Musica]